l'europe doit aider la france à se
défendre contre le terrorisme toutes les
formes de terrorisme et bien sûr et
surtout le terrorisme islamique
pour ce faire nous avons besoin de
l'europe nous avons besoin que le
parquet européen qui est en train d'être
créée par l'union européenne et aussi
les compétences de lutte contre le
terrorisme
nous avons besoin que notre agence
européenne de police europol soit
renforcé et puisse aider les états
membres à lutter plus efficacement
contre le terrorisme
nous devons également lutter
systématiquement contre les influences
extérieures contre les imams salafistes
contre l'argent qui provient d'entités
qui veulent nous déstabiliser on a bien
vu que l'europe nous apporter la
stabilité l'europe nous a apporté la
paix mais tout n'est pas parfait en
europe et notamment nous ne sommes pas
capables de contrôler l'immigration
irrégulière l'europe doit aider la
france à contrôler l'immigration
irrégulière pour ça nous les
républicains souhaitent ont deux choses
le renforcement des frontières
extérieures de l'union européenne avec
notamment la création d'un corps de
gardes-frontières européens et de
garde-côtes européen au niveau de l'
agence frontex est également le
rétablissement des frontières
intérieures
cette double barrière permettra à la
france d'être protégé contre les vagues
d'immigration irrégulière que nous ne
souhaitons pas la france doit pouvoir
choisir qui elle accueille sur son
territoire
un jour quand les frontières extérieures
sont efficaces nous pourrons à nouveau
lever nos frontières intérieures
mais pour l'instant il faut garder cette
double protection et c'est notre
engagement nous les républicains pour
défendre l'europe et pour défendre la
france à travers l'europe